bienvenue mesdames et messieurs cette
nouvelle Olympia de mathématiques du New
Jersey ce jeune garçon peut-il tout
gagner bref
bon courage pour la rentrée tu as encore
rêvé du concours oui et tu as gagné oui
bien joué et comme vous
je suis très contente cette année des
jeunes de 12 ans rejoignent notre classe
du secondaire qui est prêt à ce matin
à vrai dire j'aurais besoin de ton aide
un devoir sur papa à moi aussi il me
manque je ne saurais pas qui je suis
tant que je ne serai pas qu'il était ton
père savait bien manié les mots attends
papa était un rappeur sérieux il
s'appelle comment tu dois pas le
connaître il est mort quand j'avais 5
ans
[Musique]
salut
mais pourquoi on crie papa et oui est-ce
que tu es un fantôme
non je suis trop vieux pour avoir un ami
imaginaire
et pourtant on en est là qui est
prennent pas d'elle
non c'est pas moi je sais pas rapper
qu'est-ce que tu racontes le hip-hop est
dans ton ADN
ce matin à deux balles se prend pour un
rappeur
[Musique]
la vérité c'est que les tyrans ont peur
des rêveurs
tu n'es pas un rappeur près tu aimes les
maths mais c'est important pour moi tu
vois je te dis que c'est en toi
tu veux monter en voiture avec des
lycéens
est-ce qu'il va pas
sois toi-même fais ton mieux c'est ce
qui est important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]